protests on the street of Moscow six
weeks in a row brought an abrupt end to
the Russian parliament summer recess and
peace held an emergency session and set
up an investigative Commission yet we
don't store I'm sure that we must
investigate financing from abroad that
leads to interference in Russia's
internal politics we must look at the
activities of some diplomats who are
based on Russian territory maybe I'm
getting ahead of myself but I promise
you we will have interesting findings
the protest started in July after
several opposition candidates were
barred from running in local elections
in Moscow election officials had
signatures they needed to collect were
false normally these local elections
don't attract a lot of attention but
banning the opposition from taking part
motivated tens of thousands to protest
police have arrested thousands of
protesters and some say they were beaten
and now face serious criminal charges
this has led many more to take part to
observe as it may sound all too familiar
blaming foreigners for anti-government
protests is not only seen as a way to
distract Russian public opinion from the
real reasons behind the protests it also
portrays these protests as negatively as
being used by foreigners this could be
used to convince people not to join on
his visit to France on Monday President
Vladimir Putin said protesters have a
right to let their voice hurt but your
authority x' will do everything to
prevent violence I am a guest here and
it is not a good place to say that but I
have to since you asked we all know
about the events related to the
so-called yellow vests in which about 11
people were killed and 2,500 people
including 2,000 policemen were injured
we don't want that to happen in Russian
capital while Russian politicians say
the American accusations of Russian
meddling in the 2016 presidential
elections were false theirs are real so
it's basically the Russian version of
the Malheur and
No well we don't have a person like
Miller of course hope our result be
better compared to what he is achieved
because he achieved zero and we will
probably find something the
parliamentary commission says it will
summon journalists and diplomats it
suspects of interference so far the US
Embassy has been blamed for meddling as
have you tooth and the German channel
Deutsche Welle
step fasten al-jazeera Moscow